[Music]
this is the victory
we're receiving your signal
request to know if you're in distress
do you like the radio
there's a storm one mile south yes i am
in distress
help is on the way how many souls on
board we don't have any souls matt can
you beat me
man we have no bearing we are taking a
fun walk
man number four ready
nasty creatures
you must be the new girl
what is this where are we where we
belong
soon you'll be a whole new person
you never had a chance back there anna
chance for what
a chance to win
do you remember what happened to you
before you came here
it wasn't a very good story
so i'm giving you a new one
now
a lot of girls get even when they get
here okay guys time to go where are we
going hunting
[Music]
it feels like a nightmare that's
normal i don't belong here i want to go
back
i'm tired of seeing all the girls in
trouble
[Music]
you're getting bad
after everything i've given you
i made you into a hero you made me into
a psychopath it's the same thing
mary
alpha
yankee
you're a monster
we're all monsters
[Music]
[Music]
you